Under the United States Constitution,
Congress makes the laws and the
president enforces the laws. The law
provides authority for the president and
the agencies of the government to compel
individuals, corporations, and others to
take - or not to take - certain acts. For
example, a law authorizes the
president to collect taxes through the
Internal Revenue Service. Neither the
president nor the IRS can collect taxes,
or do anything else, without a supporting
law from Congress.
However, the laws leave the IRS and other
agencies with discretion on HOW they
enforce the law. An executive order is
the president's written direction to the
agencies of the government about how he
wants them to act when they enforce the
law. For example, President Trump issued
an executive order directing all
agencies to eliminate two regulations for
every regulation they issue. As long as the
order is consistent with the
Constitution and the law, the president
can use an executive order to tell the
IRS and others HOW he wants them to do
what Congress has authorized.
Are executive orders by President Trump a good idea?
Let us know in your comments, and also
let us know what other topics you want
AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.